hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 24 of game
programming so yesterday we took a
little look at how movement sort of
works and we also made our game focus
and today we're going to actually start
on the level class and just this episode
I'm sort of going to give you guys an
overview of what the class contains and
what the class will basically do all
right so first thing we're gonna do is
actually create the class so and I'm
actually just you know in our source
thing in a navigator here in
interstellar rain folder we'll just make
a new class and we'll put it into its
own package called level alright because
the the the level package is actually
going to be pretty big right it's going
to contain all of our different level
sub classes as well as stuff like tiles
and any other entities that actually are
contained in our level so that's why you
sort of want to make a different package
for just to organize everything we're
going to call it level and this is going
to be our primary level class now this
level class is going to do a few
different things
um because a lot of you probably don't
really have well you probably have
different ways of making levels right I
don't want to really limit you by just
showing you one way so I'm sort of going
to be constructing levels using two ways
one is just going to be very simple
random generation just to kind of
quickly and easily see if our level
actually constructs correctly without
having to actually spend a lot of time
on making the level and then the second
level is actually going to be you know
from an image file which actually
contains data as to which tile is where
so to do that what I need to
constructors because every time we make
a new level we're actually making a new
instance of the level class so the first
thing I'll do actually is I'll make two
variables called width and height so
private ends width and height again not
going to assign anything to them right
now
and width and height probably isn't even
going to be applicable um for the random
generation level I sorry for the from
file level because the width and height
will probably just get from the file
itself so this is primarily for the
random generation level the other thing
I'm going to do is actually make another
drive it in and it's going to be called
tiles and this will actually contain
data as to which tile goes where so in
other words tile idea I IDs so we know
it which are which index we actually
draw a specific tile so now for the
Constructors right public level this is
going to be the construction the
constructor that actually construction
this is going to be the constructor that
actually generates a random level so
because random levels can be any size we
have to define a size for it so in width
and in height so that when we actually
create a random randomly generated level
we actually you know specify a size as
to how big we want the level to be and
what we'll do here is we'll simply set
this dot with equal to width this stop
hype equal to height tiles equal to new
int width times height and finally will
actually create random level all right
that's what I call the method and we can
just quickly create that method so this
level again will actually generate I
might actually rename it to something
like generate generate level
all right so again it's gonna basically
all it's going to do here is going to
set the width and height of the level
create that amount of tiles on other
words we have a level that's four by
four tiles that's four times four tiles
in total so the 16 tiles in total are in
that level because obviously I'm I feel
I don't really think I need to explain
that in depth because we've got a tile
for every square meter or a square unit
so yeah and then finally once it's done
that is actually gonna run the code
which actually generates a level which
will actually look at in the future
because there's no point of doing it and
doing it now because well one I want to
give you guys an overview of this class
and second of all we actually haven't
made many tiles so maybe after we
actually have a bunch of tiles and we
have um you know a bunch of different
elements to put into our level we can
run this generation thing now the other
constructor is going to be to actually
generate or load a level from file so
what does it call a public level and
that was called string path into our
parameters this is going to take one
parameter and it's a string it's just
basically going to be the directory of
the actual level and then all we're
going to have to do here is just simply
load level and then we'll put path in as
a parameter so that here private void
load level string path and again what
this method is actually going to do is
load a level from a path now the reason
I'm doing it this way and so you can see
it's very simple is because all of the
code which actually contains width and
height is probably going to go into here
so that we can easily read the width and
height off the actual image um so from
the file when we actually load the level
file we'll just read the UM we'll just
read the
the width and height of the level from
that file itself and tiles again will
create the tiles within this constructor
we've got another we've got like a quite
a bit more to go here but they kind of
depend on other classes like tile
classes which I'm not going to get into
now but the other two main things is
public void update again this is public
don't forget and what the update method
is going to do is as you can imagine
update our level so things like um
artificial intelligence for example so
if we have like BOTS or will not really
boss but like um well yeah bots i guess
just like creatures the move around the
level that position and stuff is going
to have to be updated entities the move
within the level entities that get
updated somehow within the level this is
all going to happen at 60 frames per
second or 60 updates per second within
this update method and then finally
public void render and again this is
going to render everything and this will
actually take a few parameters which
will be like the x position or the x
scroll so in other words that sort of
where we've scrolled the map to scroll
the level to y scroll again that's just
the X&Y of where the map is at and these
screen class is also going to have to be
included there because remember the
screen class is actually what draws onto
our monitor onto our game and we'll just
import that so this is sort of a quick
overview of the actual level of the base
level alright because will actually
create a subclasses to this thing where
level is their superclass which will
contain specific which will obviously
inherit all this but also contain
specific um methods and stuff like that
for for example for like a night level
or something like that will actually
just create a subclass of this so
remember the way that we sort of want to
structure our game is in a way that we
don't like we don't we want to max that
maximally reduce redundancy all right we
don't want to have to type the same code
twice at any point in time so in other
words
um
what what we're basically saying here is
let's just put everything if if any two
levels seem to have the same properties
right so for example they both or in
other words maybe all of our levels
actually depend on the time we want to
actually make a method here which will
actually probably do that because I sort
of like playing around with different
brightnesses and getting the level to
maybe even dynamically change so like
something wrong with the magnet doesn't
do is obviously there's no like time and
it there's no time of day there's no
night time maybe we could have day/night
cycles kind of like in Minecraft but um
in our realm in that God type game so
that's again something that we can put
in pop look for it I'm in fact probably
private oops
private void time and then small manage
the time because and again I'm putting
it into our main level class just
because time is going to be pretty much
in every method I'm sorry in every um it
every clean every sub class of level so
yeah remember in in this class we're not
actually going to be doing any like hard
cool things like actually rendering this
random method will be probably
absolutely empty like as in we won't
actually expand this at all will
describe the superclass for it and then
override it but this is this is sort of
like the template for our levels so so
yeah that's just how it works and again
next time we'll probably get into
actually trying to render like a test
level to the screen with multiple tiles
maybe and um and yeah we'll get out
we'll get onto it into generating like a
random just a really basic random level
so yeah until then guys hope you enjoyed
the video if you did please hit the like
button and I'll see you guys see you
guys next time tomorrow
later guys
[Music]
you
[Music]